[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Нововознесенка,
Подніпров'я і Запоріжжя]
Я варю з такого ж козячого молока,
як і хтось варить,
але сири виходять інші.
Ви запитуєте: «Чому він в нас такий
виходить, а у когось інший?»
[Олександр Макухін
Фермер, сировар]
І який є секрет цьому?
Я відповідаю дуже просто.
Секрет в тому, що я вкладаю свою душу.
Ось тому вона і така є.
Ось така сировальня.
Ми самі її зробили.
Вона працює на газу, не на електриці.
Ми робимо
десь 14 видів сиру:
італійського, голандського [сиру]
та швейцарська група сирів.
Найбільше робимо голандську групу сирів.
Це козацький сир.
Є ось такий сир: альпійський.
Це швейцарська група сирів.
Ось він.
В нього буде така корочка.
І ми... Він вже підсох.
[Цей сир] можна спускати до погребу
і там зберігати.
Я варив сир дома,
як і більшість сироварів,
десь теж, починають варити,
невеличкими ємностями,
щоб спробувати, що і як виходить.
Потім я поїхав,
навчився в школі.
Я вже там отримав, деякі рецепти,
які ми там вчили.
І потім я вже почав більше розуміти,
що таке сир, як відбуваються ті всі процеси,
і потім почав додавати і експерементувати
та знаходити якісь свої нові рецепти
і адаптувати їх під себе.
Я розумію і зрозумів важливу річ одну.
Якщо ти хочеш робити гарний продукт,
то потрібно мати своє молоко.
Якщо ти просто маєш сироварню,
а молоко купуєш —
це дуже проблемна ситуація,
бо ти не знаєш, чим годують твоїх тварин,
як та чим вони хворіють та не хворіють,
хто і як за ними доглядає,
і що в результаті виходить.
Молоко — це сировина для сиру,
якщо сировина  буде нормальною,
і висококласною та високоякісною,
то і сир буде високоякісним.
Тому я прийняв рішення купити невеличку хатинку
і зробити міні-ферму.
Відкатати технологію, зробити, побачити,
як доглядати за тваринами, як вони будуть розмножуватися.
В мене не було такої практики.
Потрошку там десь щось збудував,
з'явилися тварини, почав за ними доглядати
і почав виробляти сир.
Бачу, що це вдається, отже можна
тепер трошечки більше щось робити.
Зараз продаю через інтернет,
беру участь в різних заходах,
наприклад, виставки.
Поставляю сири в кілька ресторанів.
Зараз це модно стало: багато ресторанів
хочуть вводити крафтові сири в меню.
Нема питань, приїхали та зробили дегустацію
скуштували, визначилися,
що їм сподобалось, і замовляють.
Такий у нас є погреб,
в якому зберігаються сири.
Такий цікавий сир,
йому чотири місяці.
Ми доглядаємо за ними, змиваємо плісняву, протираємо,
але є такі сири, які я залишаю,
щоб пліснява наросла.
Він покритий латексом,
який не пропускає плісняву.
Але пліснява дає йому свій варіант для витримки.
Сир, який утримується шарами плісняви,
виходить іншим.
Я роблю тут, бо я тут мешкаю,
тут є мої кози, тут є моя родина,
куди мені звідси їхати.
Тут, крім мене, ще є декілька людей і все.
Це теж нормально, бо немає конкуренції.
У нас зараз такий клімат став у Запоріжжі:
буває, по 2 місяці не буває дощів.
Коли [мої сири] коштували французи,
казали, що це є дуже цікавий феномен,
ніде у Франції, в Німеччині,
теж як на Західній Україні,
в них немає такого,
щоб [земля] висихала.
У них протягом літа трави соковиті,
а в нас вони сухі.
Кози будуть їсти,
барани будуть їсти.
У них буде інше молоко.
Йдеться про вміст якихось речовин,
з яких потім — з того молока —
буде вироблятися сир.
І сир матиме інший смак,
і він буде неповторний.
В тому і є цікавість такого району.
Я коли робив тут сироварню,
планував тут запрошувати
і місцевих мешканців для того,
щоб вони працювали,
але дуже-дуже складно знайти людей,
які б допомагали.
Дуже складно.
Чому складно?
Тому що потрібно працювати,
Це ризик, це важко.
Можливо люди перестали,
перестали хотіти працювати важко.
Але я не покладаю рук,
сподіваюсь, що знайдутся люди,
які прийдуть та будуть допомагати:
навчатся варити сири
і варитимуть їх з радістю.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Сергій Кучеренко]
[Режисерка монтажу
Юлія Рублевська]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]